وهذه صور مباشره من اغوار الاردن قرب
مستوطنه الحمراء التي وقع فيها او التي
وقعت فيها عمليه الاغوار واطلاق النار
والتي طبعا كما ذكرنا قبل قليل مراسل
العربيه افاد بارتفاع قتلى هذه العمليه
الى ثلاث مستوطنات
وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه اكدت كذلك ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي ما زال يطارد منفذي هذه
العمليه بعدها ايضا
نتنياهو اجرى مشاورات امنيه مع كبار
المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين بعد اطلاق النار اذا في هذه
المنطقه منطقه الاغوار اذا استدعاء
العشرات من ضباط الاحتياط من القوات
الخاصه الاسرائيليه ايضا مع التركيز على
الدفاع الجوي وسلاح ايضا كذلك الجيش
الاسرائيلي وحسب مراسل العربيه كذلك وصل
لموقع اطلاق النار في الاغوار بعد نحو 20
دقيقه التحقيقات الاوليه مشاهدينا لهذه
العمليه تشير الى ان اطلاق النار في
الاغوار رفضه شخصان في البدايه قتلت
مستوطنتين واصيبت الثالثه بجروح وصفت
بالخطيره تابعنا واياكم ايضا عمليه ربما
اخلاء او نقل هذه المستوطنه الثالثه التي
اصيبت بجروح خطيره ليتم الاعلان قبل قليل
عن مقتلها كذلك مراسل العربي افاد بان
الجيش الاسرائيلي نشر حواجز متنقله لمنع
فرار منفذ عمليه اطلاق النار في الاغوار
والتي نشاهد صور مباشره من مكان وقوع هذه
الحادثه التي كما ذكرنا قتل فيها ثلاث
مستوطنات
او قتلت فيها ثلاث مستوطنات جراء اطلاق
النار في الاغوار